[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
break down the second movie of the air
that's about the rock fighting with
family Hobson short is out for wide
release and throughout this video I'll
be discussing everything that you need
to know about the film and its ending
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't seen the movie yet and don't
want anything ruined then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for click in this video now let's
get into my breakdown of Hobbs and sure
we follow Hobbs a huge man who's able to
rock-bottom someone and lay the
smackdown on anyone that doesn't know
their role and sure a man who can kick
the cap off the top of a bottle and is
an inspiration for bald people who think
that they look like him if they shave
their heads you should shave your head
Larry it'll make you look like Jason
Statham
it never does anyway after mi6 agent
Hattie Shaw is forced to inject herself
with the virus that can be programmed to
kill certain people we get a tail a
family that takes a few twists and turns
Hattie is Shaw's sister who's also sure
and she was forced to become a carrier
of the disease named snowflake after
coming face to face with Brixton law a
superhuman that has synthetic implants
and is able to tear through agents like
they're nothing
Brixton played by Idris Elba is an
awesome addition to the franchise and
his superhuman enhancements make him one
of the most formidable villains in the
series so far he's lethal one-on-one and
the protagonists really have to outthink
a lot of the situations with him that
they find themselves in outdone by
Hattie injecting herself with snowflake
Brixton frames the character and forces
her to go on the run which is when hops
ensure assigned to work with one another
in order to track her down we get some
incredible cameos including Kevin Hart
who shows up throughout the film and
lets you know that the bromance between
him and the rock still lives on because
they're you guessed it family in the
film we learn that the virus was created
by a shadowy organization
named Etienne who wished to kill a vast
majority of the world's population
because they believe that they are weak
at Aeon have control of the media and
several agents at their disposal of
which they used to make life difficult
for Hobbes and Shore they initially try
to recruit sure through Brixton but he
shot him and left him for dead which
forced the group to resurrect him with
machinery after contacting the professor
that created the disease they learned
that the virus can be extracted from
Hattie with a special device located at
the ATM Factory and the group then
traveled to Russia to get it as you can
imagine things don't go according to
plan and the device gets the fast and
furious treatment realizing that they
need to fix this device Hobbs suggests
that they return to his home in Samoa to
reunite with his family because this is
all about family and together he and his
brother along with the Shaw siblings
make a stand against Brixton and the
forces of Etienne the movie really kicks
it up a notch here and the classic fast
and furious themes are laced throughout
this section alongside the ass-kicking
action that you've come to expect from
the franchise whilst this story isn't
going to win any Oscars it's still fun
being along for the ride and it can't be
overstated how well the rock and
Statham's performances both drive the
plot along at pace that feels engaging
and enjoyable it was awesome seeing
Cliff Curtis here and it really ramps
the movie up from here the device is
repaired and they use it to slowly
extract the virus from Hattie however
they're not out of the woods yet
and Brixton arrives and captures her
which pretty much puts a ticking clock
on ahead the Hobbs lot and sure give
chase and this is a really heart
pounding moment that ramps up the
tension of the film in an awesome way
Hopson sure go head-to-head with Brixton
who up until this point has seemed
pretty unstoppable however they realized
that though he's lethal one-on-one his
attacks tend to leave him open when
facing two or more people the two work
together
solidifying their friendship no scratch
that
Pham ship and they manage to take him
down though sure say that you will spare
the character because he's killed him
once before and refuses to do it again
it looks like everyone is gonna get a
happy ending until Brixton is
decommissioned by the shadowy figure
that's been behind Etienne this and
time whilst we never see who this is
he's clearly a voice from Hobbes's past
as he says you don't remember me do you
it also looks like he's got plans for
the three as well as he says they
outperform their analytics and I think
that going forward whoever this is could
potentially capture one of the three and
fit them with the same cybernetics that
brixton had and thus they will be able
to control the character and potentially
the characters could end up going head
to head now whilst we don't have a clear
indicator of who exactly this is due to
the voice distortion on it I did some
detective work and after looking on IMDB
I saw that the voice actor was listed as
champ nightingale this is clearly a
pseudonym and a quick google search of
this name brings up a troll Amazon
review that was written by none other
than Ryan Reynolds Reynolds used the
moniker to write a fake review on his
own gin company and the actor of course
features earlier in the movie so it
would make sense for him to show up once
more as a new big bat going forward they
will definitely want to keep him around
and I think it sort of ties the movie
together really well it makes sense that
Reynolds would handpick Hobbes for the
mission so that he could keep an eye on
him and this kind of ties back to the
analytics line later in the film agent
Locke who Reynolds plays pops up in two
of the post-credits scenes and in both
he's desperate to recruit Hobbes his
obsession with him really enforces for
me that he was the voice behind the
entire thing and I definitely want to
see this developed in the future now on
to the post credits scenes and Wiles
have already discussed the two which
revolve around agent lark trying to
recruit Hobbs once more the other two
also set up things for the future
Hobbs returns home to introduce his
daughter to the rest of the family and
it seems like in future films they could
be helping out once more and the shores
return to prison to bust their mother
out of it clearly she will be in future
films - and it looks like we are due for
a big shore family reunion in the next
Batson Furious film and now on to my
review so as I'm sure you can guess
Hobbs and Shore is a blast from start to
finish we are so deep into the Fast &
Furious franchise and somehow the series
is still coming up with ways to reinvent
itself which is always awesome to see
the film is pretty predictable but
there's still so much to enjoy here that
you don't really mind watching at all
play out Hobson sure
an excellent team up movie that smartly
sets up a sequel and shells a direction
that the films could be heading in down
the line
Hobson sure is a worthy spin-off to The
Fast and the Furious franchise and
that's why it gets an 8 out of 10
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
the film and if you want to see more
from the to comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure that you
subscribe to the channel for more
breakdowns like this every day if you
want something else to watch after this
then make sure you check out my full
breakdown of all of the deleted scenes
from Avengers endgame which would be
linked at the end I show every scene
that we have so far and discuss why it
was cut so it's definitely worth
watching if you want to know more if you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this I also just want to let you know
that we're currently giving away a free
copy of Avengers endgame on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Hobson's short in the
comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]